don't mind me just sitting in front of
my fireplace in England you could take
moving that way didn't allow you to see
that any better see it yeah this deep
dark hole not just a physical
representation of my feelings but an
actual practical fireplace do the words
practical and fireplace ever go together
I don't I really just don't think so
this is the second time on my book tour
that I have been in a hotel room with a
working fireplace and you seem great you
just seem like a lot of work you're like
a girl that shows up on a date and she's
like making balloon animals and you're
like oh wow okay you have some very
clear hobbies but you just seem so
difficult I slept for 16 hours last
night that's not the start of a poem
that's just a fact
I'm wearing adidas t-shirt which makes
me feel very European an adidas t-shirt
without your liberty on it but the
Statue of Liberty is holding an Adidas
shoe because she's just a regular lady
like me and cares about fashion and also
doesn't know how to handle her anger
correctly what is this this is the
introduction to another episode of not
too deep what were you gonna do buddy
huh were you gonna raise the roof over a
one-sided high-five are you asking a
question feel like an idiot now don't
you don't worry so if it's the fireplace
this room is full of idiots not too deep
if you did not know as my podcast why is
it here on this YouTube channel hah hah
hah hah hah hah hah sleep sleep sleep I
decide to show you so my favorite clips
from each episode of the podcast here
the light is changing what if I do this
watch this Boop call me Spielberg and
then I'll call you an ambulance because
you must be having a stroke because
that's not my name and each week I will
be introducing the clip in a completely
different way as a further means to
entice you to please keep watching my
videos this week's guest is drew Monson
he is one of my favorite internet people
just why do I say internet people why
categorize maybe you're not just a lamp
maybe you're also
what are there people if you don't know
who is okay that's fair not everyone
knows everyone
I think drew is hilarious his videos on
here make me laugh out loud which is
real and I was so rare everyone be like
la la la la la but really they're like
thumbnail we talked about our feelings
on public restrooms candy Omar the
school that he went to growing up
because he went to a school in which
there were no real classrooms and you
called your teachers by their first
names and it wasn't homeschool you
should listen to it anyway here's one my
favorite moments from the podcast
mirrors drew Monson you did it start
with I'm here at drew monster when we
were talking about paparazzi or [ __ ] I
oh no you can curse absolutely you can
do whatever you want to do yeah well I
mean within reason so cuz I don't know
you that well
well I murder brace me if I like
something I say yes my mom is great and
I love Walmart for their price
elementary school I went to a weird one
more like oh yeah you went to this like
free-thinking how did I talk about that
in a video now you talked about it to me
I'm good cuz I get so scared that people
are watching me I really do ah yeah it
was kind of like a hippie school sure I
that there was basically it was no desks
no grades and call your teachers by
their first names this when it changes
things and it wasn't home school no no
okay that sounds like how you define
home school you told them dad and that's
not dad's name not when you aim is mine
how did a day operate it was a lot of
coloring every year we'd have a piece
assembly where we'd all every class
would sing songs about peace every like
you know I mean you know there's one
that just went peace peace will come
peace on earth and let it begin with me
that seems like someone like got lazy
and yeah song that was written that
morning
oh I'd say more often than not bathrooms
are kind of nice I feel like they're
little underappreciated
there's a lot of nice bathrooms out
there especially Chinese restaurants but
one of my favorite moments is when you
used to live with roommates for all the
comments in the video were they sound
hot I'm like what the [ __ ] they sound
hot like I was insulted cuz I'm like
don't I sound hot I guess you can see me
that's a very existential question yeah
it is kind of do you think you sound hot
my clothes are eyes I I can't close your
eyes oh you want to play alone no this
is one of my worst nightmares really fun
and some just shouting at me to close my
eyes I hope that you enjoyed that if you
really enjoyed it please go to
SoundCloud ride Tunes and listen to the
full episode I think you might not find
that it's awful and I highly encourage
you to go check out Drew's YouTube
channel it is really really funny and he
takes his shirt off in almost every
video so that's something that brings
you to the yard go watch otherwise I'll
be here Monday Wednesday and Friday so
don't forget to subscribe and leave a
comment why do I always feel so gross
doing that but truly and honestly if you
would subscribe that would be great
because we're really close to three
million here and it would just be being
fantastic to finally pass three million
because numbers define us there's a man
I don't know
also I'm here in England and I'm doing a
bunch of book signings for grace and
style the art of pretending you have it
my new book available in bookstores and
on Amazon and on thanks like your dad
you should really use a blanket to sleep
and not my book so if you want to come
to any of those book signings go to grey
style book.com slash tour check out
where they will be happening and click
the links to register because I would
love to see you what I'm okay if you
don't show up because that got weird I
fully understand that and I take full
responsibility for it but you get to
offer contribute something someone out
there bothered by this I know it's in
the comments I'm sorry I didn't realize
this until just now is this making it
worse